[Applause]
[Music]
okay seriously you guys the internet
needs to pipe down we see everyone
comparing Taylor Swift's bbm a
performance to Beyonce's Coachella
performance and I'll be honest I am so
not here for it if you missed all the
drama though here is the backstory
Taylor opened her performance last night
like this viewers instantly went nuts on
Twitter comparing it to Beyonce's
Coachella a homecoming performance this
user even said quote so I guess Miss
Taylor Swift wanted to see how it feels
to be Beyonce Beyonce fans even went so
far as to compare Taylor's fringe dress
to Beyonce's fringe boots okay so
there's a few things that I need to
point out this pic of Taylor doing the
whole marching band drumline thing is
from 2009 you guys on her fearless tour
that is over a decade ago and there's
this scene from her you belong with me
video again doing the whole marching
band thing I'm sorry did Beyonce invent
drum lines did I miss something it's
also 2019 and we are still pitting women
against women it's not okay it has to
stop also remember this Beyonce Taylor
Kanye VMA moment go Taylor
I'm really happy for you I'm let you
finish but Beyonce had one of the best
videos of all time videos on Tara that
was also in 2009 also a decade ago and
clearly bantay are just fine in fact
Beyonce showed up to Taylor's 25th
birthday party nearly 5 years ago
they also hugged it out at the Grammys
in 2016 so again this is really a
non-issue I feel like we should be
celebrating
both ladies they're both fierce talented
gorgeous and hey they both like
drumlines
who freakin cares what do you guys think
though can we just let this be let me
know what you think and for all the
latest on Taylor and Beyonce make sure
that you stick with all things et until
next time I'm Katie Krause bye for now
[Music]